resignation we're gonna watch the Super
Mario Brothers movie finally we did not
see this movie which I believe is the
most successful film of all time in the
movie theaters just so we can react to
it with you here so you guys are like
you should support the movie theaters
billions of people already took care of
that for us we got a job to do John how
you doing Mamma Mia I'm excited are you
excited to catch every single Easter egg
everyone and know every obscure
character's name guys for every Easter
egg we miss you make sure to comment in
the comment boxes below also leave it a
like that would be very much appreciated
I want to say a massive thank you to
everyone who has supported the reject
Nation about getting yourself a space
baby's taste shirt it is almost our
number one most selling shirt at
shopzeroeddition.com I feel like it fits
in tuned animated Guardians you know is
Chris Pratt it all where it's it works
it's connected thank you guys Link in
the description box you want to go get
yourself a space baby shirt today oh
yeah and lastly I want to say a special
thank you to everyone who has followed
us at our patreon page by becoming super
sexy rejects we've been getting so many
patrons due to the fact that we've been
covering so many movies full-length
Reaction watch the laundry sink with
your own copy of Mario available for
them over there and also we cover
several things exclusively with reaction
Heights and watch songs included for our
patrons alrighty guys let's get to it
ah yes
it's already working on me
animation looks great yeah
Spartans
all right
so cinematic it's a little bit cool in
3D I bet open the gates or die
locked Gates
[Music]
[Laughter]
house
oh brought ice to a lava fight a taste
of our Fury
[Laughter]
I do not
oh
for penguins
that is threatening it's Epic no
the star yes
oh no
oh
nice oh there's a star yeah okay finally
found it and now no one can stop me
yes
I've collected a bunch of real brothers
on the brothers
Mario Brothers oh my God Easter eggs
Galore damn I am so
quick is it too much too much it's a
perfect nice oh it's got the colors of
the original Mario is that the original
voice actor I bet if it is
The Wrecking Crew guy tell me have you
even gotten one call since you left me
to start your dumb company as a matter
of fact Spike we have nice
you're a joke and you always will be no
he's gonna prove himself in this movie
he's gonna become a badass a chosen one
that game inspired Wreck-It Ralph he's
come on you know you can't be scared all
the time and you'd be surprised
GameCube
[Laughter]
that's great you called us because we
can be there and we can fix it right
away okay that's so perfect
Brothers
yes I love the GameCube love that is
resurfaced lately
[Music]
okay that's also in Guardians of the
Galaxy yeah
wherever so strides Chris Pratt boy the
Beastie Boys are not far behind
oh that's great nicely done
oh that's fantastic
sorry
yeah the up and downs oh
yes right down the pole oh
the princess is in another castle that
was fun
[Music]
what have you done Luigi what
Francis is here
kill the dog
[Music]
ah super shower Brothers
no
[Laughter]
whoa jeez love the way this is shot yeah
and the textures are gorgeous
no it won't
all comes down to one wrench every time
oh
[Music]
no jeez
laughs
great plungers
Star Fox
oh that's the movie I want to make boy
we are very close to fixing this
somebody else somebody say Brooklyn save
Brooklyn save Brooklyn this
ah duck hunt where the little duck logo
yeah I'm sure we've already missed like
20 Easters I should have brought my duck
hunt gun
Mario
yes down the warp tube
this is a gorgeous looking movie
yeah a lot of the environments look real
oh boy
[Music]
come on you're below the Mario no
[Applause]
dude
what is this place
laughs
well if you're impressed by that just
get ready man you gotta whirl the tubes
ahead of you Luigi
hold on to your mustache
bye Frost enter the Stargate
I'm telling you nothing can hurt us as
long as we're together sure
oh no the pie Frost it's also like a
little Doctor Who Doctor Mario
's around here somewhere please pleased
to meet you I'm toad
Um Kingdom now that is a cruel twist of
fate that is what he hates see last time
I saw him he was falling through a pipe
it was foggy and I believe there was
brother
is landed in the dark lands
about control uh-oh why'd you say that
name
[Music]
good score hang on Luigi
wow Mario you've adjusted to this
magical Wonderland really fast
oh
is that a Yoshi
it's like a little ghost turtle yeah
Turtle oh or skelet turtle
oh
I could watch this all day I'm saying
bring me that Luigi's Mansion movie
oh my God please do a Luigi's Mansion
move
how cool and visually striking this is
yeah like we're in Resident Evil now
Castlevania
yes chanterelle
you just have to blow into It Antiques I
love it they're all 8-bit
[Music]
love it love it and they're good at
using the motifs but still having it
feel like a real movie score
oh
cool yes
[Music]
how would you navigate this just like
the sewer
here we are
we on
it's like the N64 version
here we go
oh hey I need to see the princess what
princess I never heard of any princess
oh wait I did a princess though is in
another Castle
it's not falling for that I don't like
it
[Music]
what do you guys um what do you want to
eat anything anything your hearts desire
nice
counsel your attention Bowser has found
the Superstar and is headed toward our
kingdom no their Mad King doesn't make
alliances the Kongs will never agree I
can convince him I'll leave for the
jungle Kingdom in the morning that's
gonna be cool
open
make fun of me all you want but you were
gonna help me find my brother please
okay let's see what you're made of
that's quite a negotiation if I was
cutting through every ounce of fat yes
no debate
whoa
nice looks like the Lego version I was
gonna say where's the Lego Mario movie
[Music]
it's like a training course you can
finish this
watch and learn
way to go Peach
wow oh she doesn't need a protector
the action visuals are gorgeous
as a fan of my existence
[Music]
hey I love it look out of uh Mario too
That was supposed to do that with the
power-ups they give us special abilities
really go on eat it make you big and
strong
time to trip out man
whoa whoa dang
[Music]
oh we've all been there buddy
oh yeah when you get hit you lose the
power
come on
needle drops 1980s
worst
yep
having sense memory flashbacks
come on get the top don't look down I'll
come on Mario we
young journey ahead of us mustache
but I didn't make it make it you almost
did no one gets it right away I was not
good at it worse than you you're full of
crap lady I grew up here okay now you're
just trying to make me feel better no
is it working a little bit yeah yeah ah
YouTube
[Music]
Goombas
references
my Army Cooper
Goombas whatever those things are
I will ask their princess to marry me in
a fairy tale wedding okay
doesn't she hate you of course she hates
me but that makes me love her all the
more her heart-shaped bangs the way she
floats in the breeze that's interesting
what if she says no
then I will power up with this star and
destroy the Mushroom Kingdom prepare
yourselves for the best wedding ever
I guess that's why you kidnap a princess
hahaha
Baby Mario I love that they even kind of
brought back this design
[Music]
will stop uh booty he's not important
you're important Mario you're coming
with us
jump in the cannon
Yoshi's hey Russell
oh my God a Jack Black song
[Music]
this is something von Koopa I understand
I love it they let him do this HSP just
peaches
[Laughter]
I was about to ask if they let him
improv this
why'd you interrupt no a mustachioed
human has arrived in the Mushroom
Kingdom the princess has been training
him they are up to something sire
what
yes Ludwig von Koopa where did he come
from
look in the mirror you'll have nothing
to worry about I know that I'm not
threatened
oh Jack Black is great yeah
I just finished Kung Fu Panda 3 so
it's kind of fun just switching to this
an hour later yeah don't worry we're
going to save him
that Firepower
nice
took me in raised me like one of their
own you're clearly from Earth your
parents are probably so worried maybe
you're from my world there's a huge
Universe out there
with a lot of galaxies yes Super Mario
Galaxy yeah
maybe you just gotta go through that
pipe Peach and your parents yeah I mean
it seems like you could easily trace it
back to
what is your name
Luigi Mario there's a human traveling
with my fiancee do you know him no like
they twirled somebody else's mustache do
you think I know every human being with
a mustache wearing an identical outfit
with a how with the letter of his first
name on it because I don't know
[Music]
since it's fine camera attractive hey
where am I
foreign
what is that star's name
[Music]
Lumia There's No Escape
only hope is the sweet relief of death
I thought that star can can get out of
there I don't know problem it seems like
we are here to see the king follow me
time for a little Diddy Kong race is
that Funky Kong
[Music]
this is cool this is really cool
ah great reference
oh wow
yeah I get the Boost
[Music]
yes
they got the updated Mario Kart in here
[Music]
interesting voice choice
we're not leaving without your army
defeat defeat my son
great rig
GS
let's go let's get it going thank you
Fred Armisen that's Fred Armisen yeah I
think so
wow so many Kongs
awesome
[Applause]
here we go
DK rap
[Applause]
dude okay Donkey Kong okay simmer down
I said simmer down
[Applause]
[Music]
ah okay guess you're not getting my Army
oh God
is this what you came for you
it is on like a Donkey Kong
unlike me
oh nice you're about to pick on someone
your own size
it's a different kind of mushroom yeah
yeah
it's tiny yep
[Music]
[Laughter]
it actually works really well yeah yeah
the platforms yes yeah oh that's cool
barrels the Donkey Kong arcade classic
yes oh here we go oh come on
he's just a human how can he withstand
the pain
that's right
[Music]
good fake out
catsuit I'm a cat cool
awesome uh put some respect on that cat
suit
[Music]
take that as a yes
Mario Mario
we've located Bowser's ship he's gonna
ride private the Mushroom Kingdom by
Sundown we're gonna need cots
[Music]
yes
I normally love Fred Armisen but I'm not
a big fan of the choice of the voice he
could be older and crankier
go
I love how to structure this to get to
references 64 on that shoulder plate
oh yeah
it's like an Iron Man reference
the motorcycle
toad
I usually play as toad yeah man get that
Speed and Agility I hear you
to the Mushroom Kingdom and the biggest
fight Our Lives
oh
what's the shortcut gonna be so it's not
gonna be a race
nah well that we know of
Princess Peach
here we are
I guess love really makes a guy come out
of his shell
[Laughter]
we have found
for their secret
s oh they think they can surprise me huh
two can play at that game
Mad Mario Fury Road that's gonna have
Anya Taylor Joyce Furious that's right
Easter eggs within Easter eggs
[Music]
the rainbow the Rainbow Road
we don't drive on rainbows what are you
gonna tell me next that the turtles
aren't evil and usually pets no way back
on the Brooklyn I'll buy you a turtle
hey you like the turtles
um
[Music]
you know I would often play as Bowser in
uh Mario Kart so this is fitting yeah
come on get a spiked one
bananas no
no this really is like Mad Max Mad Max
Rainbow Road
God it's so hard driving
now jump off one ramp and fall onto
another and cut everybody two laps
whoa
[Applause]
that would be absolutely terrifying
gnarly Mario drift
throw the show
oh
damn peachy we whooping ass
oh my
God toad
[Music]
holy moly
this is how you princess
[Music]
oh God
you never don't want to quit Mario
we're just murdering characters hey man
they're just Koopas their lives mean
nothing you
me what
oh blue shell blue shell it's
inescapable
it's a cool sci-fi shot I feel like it
should have been the Red Shell because a
blue shell usually goes to the front of
the race line yeah whereas a red shell
you can specifically Target it clearly
the creators need to study up with their
Mario Kart
oh no save him we need to spit off yeah
in all the spin-offs
not bad
you saved my life yeah well I won't tell
anyone good please don't
[Laughter]
this is great delivery
I was scared yeah
and the lighting and the water like
[Music]
yeah these moving shots are incredible
princess
we lost the
SE
Wowie
[Music]
I stole this star for us
I guess God love really makes a guy come
out of his shell oh no buddy
no I like this motive I would never
marry you
maybe you
see there
oh I'll marry you just don't hurt my
toads
that's how you want to get a yes just
marry him what's a big deal it's your
job you're a woman it's like there's no
other humans here how do you even know
what the concept of a human is
[Laughter]
where you allowed be ritualistically
sacrifice
yay well at least your brother isn't
gonna die because of you at least you're
not gonna die with your dad thinking
you're a joke
yeah well my dad thinks I'm a joke too
yeah well your dad's right
just just leave me alone I've never met
your dad but he sounds brilliant just go
over the corner and smash some stuff
smash
monkeys I think Donkey Kong is my
favorite
huh
[Music]
that was convenient
wow
that was a gorgeous shot
that's a nice detail
oh King Boo
you really thought I'd marry you
kinda I'd never marry a Monster
ice ice
[Music]
they gotta be up there
no
[Applause]
[Music]
come on fire suit
fire Kong yes
oh
[Music]
yes yes
love the leaf my favorite suit from
Mario three
[Music]
oh no dude Peach is so badass in this
movie is that murder
oh
Luigi no
no save my boy
Donkey Kong more than just a Smasher
that would be a terrifying scenario yeah
hold on oh no
[Music]
Mario
I told you see the squares were together
everything is gonna be okay oh I wish
they were together for more of the movie
yeah really
[Music]
oh that jealousy breakthrough with pure
rage
the Mushroom Kingdom
oh no
no oh no
what are you gonna do Mario
you know just hop on top of it real
quick
foreign
[Music]
oh sure no totally
send it to Earth
make him a pet
[Music]
oh
all right
just out into the circuits of time
whoa
oh no this pancake's good though to save
Brooklyn you gotta first put Brooklyn in
a lot more danger yes
huh
Brooklyn
oh Mario
whoa damn when there's something strange
in the neighborhood
grab it power up Mario
power up you little Italian man
wow oh my God
his strength is impeccable ruined
my wedding I was finally gonna be happy
where are you now you will suffer oh the
luck card thing on the side of the
building
yeah Peach come out
and do the whole thing in your Italian
accent leave him alone
Mario
you just don't know when to quit that's
his problem themes
[Music]
no that's mine come on Marion power up
thanks you just gave him a boost yeah
seriously
oh
my man
I would get the star
oh
awesome that's pretty cool that's pretty
cool
oh
[Music]
thank you
and the Run
that's right Mom and Dad yo
Mamma Mia
[Music]
love it
right into his own nose
kick it ass
now that's what I call a Mario Party
that's it for the Super Mario Brothers
[Applause]
you guys
[Music]
I love how they have the original guy
there yeah it's almost as if you could
have been in the movie nah it's
impossible
which has way too much
Guardians too
is that Captain Falcon's car on the on
the wall Falco punch
[Music]
all right well done
Mario
now that's a happy ending or is it
because everything's over now and all
that's left is you and the infinite
voice
Boop
foreign
well done well done well done
all right
I'm assuming there's going to be a
post-credits scene gotta be at least
five
all right well might as well start
reviewing it now sure thing review
Starts Now
and then we raise our volume up and we
freak out when a scene starts all right
review starts in three two one and John
take it away ah this was very very much
fun I mean you know I I had heard
varying things from people about like oh
how the story moves and yes like the
story itself is straight to the point as
you said no fat on it but it was super
fun super colorful and just like
beautifully realized in terms of just
like the designs the textures the
lighting the camera work the actual
choice to make it feel like real camera
work and stuff like that all the
different uh characters they chose to
include out of the pantheon uh yeah I
mean I think there's certainly ways they
can build on this they can you know make
an even more satisfying Super Mario Bros
movie especially when there's more Luigi
for my money but uh you know for for
where we are in video game movies and
stuff like that uh this was super duper
fun and uh and yeah I would be happy to
see this on a big screen at some point
yeah yeah I mean I feel like this was a
there was uh
uh a good it was a good movie as a
a good movie but there was a great movie
that they could have made out of it 100
and that's the part of me that I'm like
oh I could see the great movie here and
like you don't really have to
change anything about like who the
characters are necessarily it's just it
could have
they could have just taken their time a
little bit more and flesh more things
out it needed a little bit of that Phil
Lord and Chris Miller touch I think yeah
I don't think I did myself any favors
just finishing Kung Fu Panda 3 which is
the weakest of the Kung Fu Panda movies
uh still love that movie uh at the same
time like probably shouldn't have just
watched that movie right after which
does do a lot more of like character
building flushing scenes out and
fleshing out the characters to get to
the point let's put this up the audio up
Mario Luigi and a donkey come true
Princess Peach at the end of life
I'll make you mine yes
yes awesome awesome has he performed
this life
no
little guy you're
here
oh
damn
yeah and like I think the voice over
work was pretty great I have a couple of
mixed opinions about uh the direction
they took with Chris Pratt's Mario uh
because I thought like the overall
Choice was good let's just start with
the rattle off the good ones right I
don't want to be too cynical here at the
very top because the way I would overall
packages like I understand this movie
for kids and I think it's a kids movie
it's pretty Rock Solid like it's a solid
kids movie I could totally see this
being the kind of movie that parents
love their children to go witness and
you can even put on the TV multiple
times like for children it's fantastic
and I guess the reason why I was making
the Kung Fu Panda comparison was because
I was like oh I'm used to you know like
in the animated medium of like movies
that are like really for the whole
families that even as an adult you can
really appreciate it so that's so I
thought there were like elements lacking
in storytelling but as a fan of the
Mario games yeah no the the references
and the Easter eggs and all the
Nostalgia elements were totally working
for me whenever they were on screen
because there were some beautiful
animation in here from beginning to end
and so many I'm sure we missed plenty of
references that were like in the
backgrounds or whatever maybe some that
were front and center that we didn't
catch uh however like then they did
bring a lot of that visually to life it
was it was gorgeous and it does play on
that nostalgic feeling so as a Mario fan
I was satisfied with a lot of that in
regards to doing that especially
compared to like the you know Mario live
action movie that came in a couple days
decades ago this was this was amazing
and I thought Bowser was great right I
mean I think uh I love the choice of
having me in love with peach yeah no I
thought that was a nice I mean like why
else I guess would you be kidnapping
this princess over and over and over
again if not for some kind of political
game then for love and uh yeah I thought
that was a really fun way to just give
Bowser some kind of flavor that you
could latch on to and I I would agree
pretty much with everything you just
said it's like there are those moments
especially where like Mario and Peach
are learning about each other or they're
bonding like you know there's not really
any you you don't come to a movie like
this for like character development but
there are a couple key moments where I
was like yeah if you let this breathe
and you didn't like Rush directly past
the meat of this little scene we could
have something that's like touching and
that yeah endears you beyond the
functionality of being you know just a a
recreation of all the you know major
tenets of Mario and Donkey Kong and
whatever else but it had moments where
you could see that it's like it had a
heart but it could have used more of a
beating heart everything about it was
there was there was constantly something
there like oh this chemistry of a Donkey
Kong and their the competition and the
bickering like oh yeah a lot of this is
a great great outline no totally solid
outline here but the the lead into a lot
of things and the building of a lot of
things just could have been way more
fleshed out and you could just see like
there's a there's a greater more
emotionally fulfilling and funnier movie
too yeah because if you play up a lot of
more of the emotions and like play into
more like with Cranky Kong and Donkey
Kong then some of the jokes would even
work a lot stronger as well so there was
a lot of opportunities that I thought
they could have made for again like I
said like a strong just a stronger
overall movie like Voice work was great
Peach was as awesome as I expected her
to be I thought Anya Taylor Joy did an
excellent job craved more Luigi because
I think Charlie day was perfect casting
for Luigi yeah absolutely perfect and
and the opportunity to hear them
together because I really like their you
know back and forth but you know like
because Luigi is so relegated through so
much of this like I did find myself
wanting a bit more of that because I
don't know like the chemistry and uh I
don't know I feel like growing up you
know everybody has if you grew up on
Mario games like I was a Luigi kid I I
usually was like if given the
opportunity I was like yeah I won't be
Luigi and so like you know you want I
think that Rapport and I mean you don't
get like a Wario or a Waluigi in this
but you you know you want to feel like
the Mario brothers are both well
represented here yeah and yeah it's like
you do have a great choice in Charlie
day and you know I know Chris Pratt has
received so much of the attention good
and bad for this
um and yeah it's like I thought he was
nice I like that they account for the
Italian accents and the commercial and
stuff like that like that's kind of
cheeky and fun the rest of the time
Mario kind of reminded me a bit of of
Mark Wahlberg but not in a way that was
like bad or distracting uh I I did think
his performance lacked an energy though
sure everyone else really even with a
choice like Fred armisen's who I wasn't
a big fan of the choice
[Music]
I want to lay down a prediction but I
don't want to ruin it if I'm right
I'll do that yep
Godzilla 99 ending
yeah good tease I was like we didn't get
I mean we saw some Yoshi's maybe they
shouldn't have shown any Yoshi yeah well
that would have been more exciting I
think if we didn't see I feel like Yoshi
if there's no Yoshi anything short of
having Yoshi be an actual character in
an actual you know like psychic Steed to
Mario I think is gonna cause people to
be like where's Yoshi but uh back to
Chris Pratt I did I mean I'd love to see
more I'd love to actually see Yoshi in a
sequel but to Chris Pratt yeah there was
I was like oh The Voice choice is not
bad I actually thought the voice Choice
worked and worked for this movie
um I was like yeah okay yeah we didn't
have to shy away from that in the
marketing it worked for this movie
however as the film kept going and maybe
it's because I wasn't truly everything
was just always like on a cute level but
lack substance to me and I I wasn't like
truly emotionally invested in Mario like
I was on board for the adventure because
I'm a Mario fan and I like seeing like
Mario Kart come to life and all that uh
but I wasn't like you know strongly
rooting for Mario here yeah and maybe it
had something to do with my emotional
investment in him I did think Chris
Pratt's uh Direction was surprisingly
like restrained for an animated movie
yeah it's funny this does seem to be one
of those things where I can feel a lot
of different choices being made among
the voice cast I I like most everybody
to some degree that they got but the two
characters that I think were at the
right energy level for the pace of the
movie and just the way the movie chose
to yeah kind of gloss over you know like
the emotional beats and themes are
touched upon in like singular little
moments and then you move on so it's
like Donkey Kong and Bowser were the two
voices Jack Black and Seth Rogen that
felt like perfectly attuned to what
we're getting as well as what the
characters are as well and Charlie Day
yeah absolutely only only wanting for
the fact that he just doesn't get a lot
of time to do his thing
um but yeah I would agree it's like the
movie moves at such a pace and I think I
remarked early on when Louis G's in the
forest at first I was like oh this is
kind of intense but as things go on it
mostly derives intensity from just being
such a fast-paced movie and having such
beautiful visuals because yeah it's like
this whole thing about Mario not wanting
to be some kind of joke to his dad and
uh Donkey Kong and identifying with that
and them you know like it really kind of
fell into that trap of like okay we
established a character conflict and
we're wrapping it up right away because
we gotta move along and we're not gonna
do a scene about it we're just gonna
kind of acknowledge it and then have the
updated character beat and move on yeah
and so I feel like a movie yeah it
really was and I felt like Chris Pratt
especially almost seemed like he wanted
to go for something that had like a
little more feeling in it and I was like
dude you're you're getting drowned out a
bit in the cacophony and luckily you
know this movie isn't really concerned
that much with that stuff so it's not
like a big deal but at the same time
it's noticeable it's a little noticeable
uh yeah I mean you know like a lot of
peaches stuff that they give her like I
thought I knew Taylor Joy did a good job
but like so much of her character is
pretty much action lines directing where
the plot's going yeah I think the
storytelling it did at the end of the
day it's like the the thing that kept
this movie alive was certain voice
performances and consistent beautiful
animation throughout yeah that energy
yeah so just to me it kept the movie at
like a fine level to me but the
storytelling was the part where as it
really it just bugs me strongly because
it's like it's right there yeah yeah
it's right there but they don't give you
I I don't really care about I'm not
worried about Peach and the Peril there
for the Mushroom Kingdom it's kind of
like you just like get it out of the way
yeah no it feels everything the
conflicts feel requisite except and and
they don't even really give you any time
to you know Peach isn't gonna marry
Bowser but I feel like that is the
closest we get to some kind of
interesting actual plot Dynamic yeah is
watching how the whole marriage thing is
is going to unfold and then pretty quick
it's like no I was never going to marry
you and we're just back to fighting and
you know it's it's fine but yeah there's
so much here that's interesting and it's
contained within this one movie that you
wouldn't need a sequel to explore well I
I think too you know I could already
hear like certain comments coming in of
being like what do you guys watch just
wanted a cute fun movie and that's what
we got and yeah
and I will say it's a cute fun movie
that's a hundred percent right I do
think though that we are also in a day
and age where we get a lot of animated
movies that are like truly expensive
with a big voice cast like this yes
where they have something that is truly
emotionally engaging and you feel the
stakes throughout and like you know
Chris Pratt was like in The Lego Movie
you know like we have these at these
actors in here and it's it's the it's a
Mario movie so I do think that it could
have been more than especially when you
are presenting the pieces for it to make
it more than just passable kids movie
entertainment and that's only where I'm
coming from on it well and let's see
well and then you're aiming this not
only at kids you're aiming this at
people who grew up in the 80s and 90s
who had all that stuff and who would
probably also want a little bit more
oomph in their story not your only only
aiming it towards them but like there's
so many 80s needle drops and things that
are clearly only for or or mainly for
that side of the audience that includes
us that would want yeah something a
little more to sink your teeth into
alongside you know like the Mario games
aren't always the deepest in terms of
emotional plotting obviously but you
know we all have an emotional connection
to that and I think you want to
replicate something akin to that with a
movie like this yeah because they had
all the they had all the points there of
you know Mario is is not uh looked his
career Pursuits and his Endeavors or not
look fondly upon by his family uh he
feels like he's not good enough and you
know Luigi rely so much on Mario
protecting him and then he's if they
don't even really lean too much into the
fish out of water quality with Mario and
even with the training segment I'm like
oh we could have really done something
here where you really feel like you got
to root for him or Donkey Kong feeling
like he's not good enough and his father
his father the way his father views him
and then we could have really had a
strong truly strong bonding moment over
that with them finding that kinship and
Rapport due to feeling like they're not
good enough and they got to overcome
this together you know like and the
Peril could have really felt real or not
real but you know actually
tangible to the point where you're like
yeah go get him yeah you want some that
some of that emotional swell yeah so I I
did miss I I did I would be lying if I
said like I I wish we I really it does
it does leave me thinking about that
because everything else that I'm like an
admiration appreciative of I feel like I
definitely expressed during this
reaction of the video like I feel like I
expressed that throughout the best
things about it are very immediate yeah
not to say that they're all surface
level but they are immediate for the
most part though it's a pretty service
level
yeah and I I think a sequel though could
improve upon it you know like I I I
think out of the video game movies I'd
still prefer the Sonic ones uh like this
looks better this is more visually
impressive but I still prefer the Sonic
movies Sonic surprises you with heart
and I think that is the thing is like
you could look at Super Mario and be
like we're not coming for a plot or or
things like that but I'm like every
animated movie especially of this
variety certainly benefits from people
coming out and going well I didn't
expect to be moved or to care yeah
exactly this went above and beyond my
expectations and I mean this they have
so many things going for them and so
much so many resources clearly that they
I don't think it would have been too
taxing to go above and beyond in those
departments yeah no but I think on the
on the surface stuff that all does work
though like the music is great I love
how it was a constant Riff on the a lot
of the variations of the Mario themes
throughout the game not just the main
tune uh and I I thought actually king of
Michael key as toad was good yeah I
enjoyed his his performance as well and
the the Mario Kart sequences the action
sequences uh because a lot of them are
are a lot of the sequences to what was
cool about the references is that it
didn't just purely rely on references in
their visual action scenes or their
moving camera moments like at the
beginning in Brooklyn or or when Donkey
Kong's fighting Mario like you'll pick
up on it if you're familiar with it uh
but it doesn't rely on just like hey
cool I know that like you would I would
still find it cool even if I wasn't
aware of what they're referencing yeah
you know yeah they just make the world
feel alive enough and they give you at
least that one info dump on power-ups
and I think that's most of what you need
the rest of it you know I think making
Mario a bit of a fish out of water and
introducing you to this world is a good
thing because it also hearkens back to
being a beginner at a game and also it
you know gives us an inroad to the Hero
Journey well if you're doing an animated
I think they could have really played up
him being like a true Fish Out of Water
because he's just kind of like Oh weird
yeah
yeah he used to be like freaking out
yeah especially in a place surrounded by
his least favorite food yeah yeah like
giant lava you know floating Bowser head
from the sky like there's a lot of
horror in this that doesn't really get
acknowledged heavily in a character
sense
um I like the songs that they have with
Bowser that's on the credits that uh
Jack Black was able to write uh write it
uh I I think they could definitely do a
great sequel though that's the thing is
I I do feel like this is a step in the
right direction and this they could make
a great sequel out of this and I mean
down to see a Donkey Kong movie too
because I think I think uh Seth rogans
was I did not expect to be saying that I
thought I would just only maybe some
people feel this way for like I would
love a Luigi's Mansion spin-off um but I
thought Seth Rogen was actually
they really seem like they've I felt
like they were trying to fit what CR I
feel like they had to work with Chris
Pratt to fit him into it sure whereas
they kind of mold the Donkey Kong around
Seth Rogen it felt like the perfect
blend yeah it was surprisingly natural
it felt like a nice halfway where it's
like okay Seth Rogen's got to do a
little bit of not being just Seth Rogen
but also this suits the character well
enough that like yeah when he does his
signature laugh like it it was more it's
surprisingly works yeah totally and it's
not just I only see and hear Seth Rogen
no it was the one it was it was one of
the few characters where I really was
just thinking about Donkey Kong yeah
like like a lot of the time I was aware
and and sometimes you know because I was
excited or whatever else you know about
different voice performances or because
you know you're examining them to see
how they are but he really managed to
just kind of disappear into the
character in an odd way yeah he's one of
the main he's one of the characters in
the Kung Fu Panda movies as well but
every time he's spoken those I was aware
of Seth Rogan but but here I I got lost
in the Donkey Kong performance I thought
that was really great I like the the way
they decided to ride him like I'm not
familiar with what the Donkey Kong story
actually goes like and they teased Diddy
Kong in here uh I I Diddy Kong was my
favorite to play as so I would love to
see Diddy Kong uh return that's right
Diddy Kong Racing that that game I
totally forgot I read like that so many
times totally forgot about your video
back in the day I yeah totally even when
you said it I didn't even remember it
until like right now this one like oh
yeah Diddy Kong Racing I forgot him yeah
okay man classic
you're like flying yeah yeah
totally tough it wasn't an easy game for
me no no in some ways I remember being a
bit more of a challenge to pick up than
something like a Mario Kart
yeah
I definitely thought it was and I mean
you know I've always found Donkey Kong a
bit more challenging than the arcade
Mario games yeah because it's one of
those movies where it's a fish out of
water and they come to this magical land
and then anybody you know you're kind of
like semi-chosen one to be the one to
save it the one the least unexpected
person and uh I wish I wish I kind of
cared a little bit more about Mario and
I wish I cared a little bit more about
the perilous situation these toads and
Peach was in oh yeah cause when he shows
up it's pretty much just like hey you're
another human oh you showed up right
where I'm going on this adventure I
guess come along yeah even for her that
could have been played up a little bit
more of like what is the human world
like and trying to discover it and yeah
yeah I just felt like it could be so
many options if you use an extra 20
minutes just to flush out these scenes
just to make the scenes just to enhance
the scenes just 20 more minutes could
have like then you could have added on
like a couple more minutes to a lot of
these scenes and then bam you would have
had a much stronger a much stronger film
that resonates a lot more yeah but hey
as a kids movie does the job gets the
job done yeah because I think when you
talk in the Optics of family films
that's where the lines get blurry
because you go family films that
encompasses
because like yeah it's a film for the
family but then there's like a film the
whole family
I feel like this this is a perhaps
something that flirts with that line
between being a kids movie versus being
a family movie like I feel like they
went to the kids movie route for their
actual storytelling yeah and they had a
lot of family movie themes yeah that
they just didn't really explore yeah
because yeah exactly it's like pitching
it towards the whole family because
there's there's inevitably going to be a
bunch that you know the older audience
is going to catch and is going to be
coming looking for and I feel like yeah
speaking to that would be a benefit the
next time around but like you said too
they've laid themselves a strong
Foundation which is a good thing yeah
there was a great movie there that could
have existed but uh right now we got a
really pretty good one we gotta we got a
good one that delivers on the visuals uh
that one would want and maybe you got
exactly what you wanted that's the thing
I got exactly what I expected yes I did
too and and but I didn't but I but what
Pete what was poking at me was oh but
the great one is
is wants to come out yeah it's right
there that tastes I can see it and if
that great one wasn't there yeah like
like waiting to come out of its pipe
then
I probably wouldn't have said it yeah
totally um but yeah anyway guys what did
you think about the Mario Brothers movie
did you overall love it did it did it uh
meet up to all the expectations for you
comment all the Easter eggs we missed
leave it all in the comment boxes below
uh you can subscribe leave a like or if
you're mad at us for having an opinion
that's fine uh Hey listen to the paper
David Gandy I'd like to think of you as
someone who would be a great plumber yes
you would oh I surprisingly feel like
you actually would know what you're
doing I suck when it comes to fixing my
toilet really not good at it every time
I'm trying to look up videos and usually
it's the simplest solution but I feel
like I can count on you you would
probably just burst through a pipe
yourself show up and fix it or yourself
and I would love that about you I could
see you also being the third brother get
Coy out of here you could be the third
brother here at the rejection right you
would be our Sage wise brother who keeps
us on the straight and narrow and
teaches us everything we know about life
and then I could also see you being like
Bowser wanting to marry Terror Erickson
you pervert territory
David candy David David candy
did you like this movie David
to you not like
do you wanting more
and going out and getting your like
Super Mario toys and then photographing
them in Epic ways you're also a hardcore
Christian tell us the Christian
metaphors you caught in this movie
yeah yeah well I mean clearly Peach is
uh is Mary Magdalene Mario's Jesus
Marias Jesus
and uh you know Bowser is Todd is Todd
toad is John the Baptist yeah definitely
it is yeah exactly I think we got it and
then you know Peter Luigi can be Simon
Peter who starts the church there you go
four shout outs in one you are the Jesus
of our patreon page thanks for being
here David
foreign